[Applause]
who like help podcast man
emily choppa is here um hey man i want
to say congratulations on the album
appreciate that long time coming for
sure
two years then two years bro it's crazy
because like
you still ain't even 18 bro
you've had a legendary couple of years
picked up a lot of plaques oh my god i
just picked up some new ones today i saw
that
i don't know which camera i'm looking at
like whichever uh this this is the one
that's just on you right here
okay don't worry about that i said it
but you're not i saw you just picked up
some new plaques uh
uh walking down is officially gold
probably close to platinum by now it is
planned on we just gotta
put in a certification for plano i think
they come make no money we ran now we
got about four of them one for cause
they said they can make no money
how many um do you know how many
certifications you have now like as far
as like gold and platinum records
it's like 11. that's crazy
11 you know what was crazy about when
you first came in too that i respected
was uh
off the rip you uh you stayed
independent for a while yeah
you did the united masters play which
you could have probably had any deal you
wanted at that time
it was a lot of labels a lot of people
i'm curious like what what was
the thought process behind that i know
your parents are really close to you
like
what was the idea of like you know
mashing out a little bit longer on the
indie route than just taking that quick
that quick bag that anybody else
probably your age or position might have
probably taken
it was just it was just like pretty much
been on yourself knowing like what you
was worth
like knowing what you could have did in
the long run to the point to where you
can come back
to the labels and then you can pretty
much make your deal instead of them
making you the deal
you call the shots yeah for sure so like
that's what it was and i got to own my
music
and get my label my own level so i mean
it was a fair win and i feel like like
that weight that weight was really
important because i feel like if i would
have signed
i wouldn't did this [ __ ] i woulda i
would have been saying that would have
been known
you took some [ __ ] deal that the
label had all the leverage on
yeah for sure i don't know how the music
goes on all the masters
you would have like you would have been
unhappy after a year
because we've seen a lot of artists
after like nine months being on a major
they go on twitter and they start
[ __ ] on their label and
we've seen it um now it's crazy because
like
being like a kid man like and you and
you having the idea to bet on yourself
is like i always that's how i've been my
whole life like i'd rather better myself
than put my
uh you know my [ __ ] in someone else's
hands you know what's
in the show cause what you're trying to
get you already got you just gotta
get there touch tyler um congrats to on
the uh double xl freshman man
for sure well deserved arguably you
should have been on it last year
last year you could have been on the
last year
but this year uh i thought they did a
solid job on the cover there's a few
people that you know maybe
you know i thought my mind could have
made it that didn't but uh
how did you feel getting on that cover
like was that something that was always
like a goal of yours
yeah i mean like it's something you look
up to like when you was little like
there's some [ __ ] you see
on youtube i used to stay going on
youtube looking at all the freestyles
saying
who had the best who had the worst and i
was like i when i get on here one day
i'm gonna know what not to do like
so i've really been prepared for that
like all my life because i was always
thinking like
how would i do if i free staff like
because i know sometimes it'd be hard
for me to freestyle but i feel like
my double exhale freeze to the shoes i
don't know why this [ __ ] was hard as
[ __ ]
you've been knowing like okay i saw this
guy [ __ ] up
and i saw what this guy did right i
ain't trying to be no me
girl i ain't trying to be no clown and
you know that's hey that looks so fresh
with freestyles
it's either great or is bad for you oh
god 100
um when you when you did your site for
who were you doing your cipher with
the cyphers i was with polo oh well
what he wanted it was raw wave little tj
um what's her name chica
yeah chica see that's the one let me
redo it for because i can i
i always forget her name like i don't
want to feel like i'm just leaving her
help
cause i she was cool but chica it was
raw wave chica
besides yourself did you get this did
you get to see uh
any anyone else's freestyles there like
like
i'm sure you went off but like like were
you like was there anyone else who you
were like yeah that their their [ __ ] was
pretty hard it was like we went in
with nobody doing the freestyles like
the freestyles was by itself
rod wave is singing for sure he was
singing that's it there's no way right
like rod wave is hard
out there i ain't gonna lie on the side
for rod he kind of i think he was
rapping
if i recall he was rapping he went in on
the floor
i like i like this [ __ ] though man that
was crazy
yo his voice is incredible shout out to
saint peter hey did you see the uh munch
the much dank official parody they did
of you and i's interview
brother [ __ ] funny like every every
interview i go into i'd be like thinking
like damn i just know they gonna pick
this [ __ ] up because i'd be doing some
slow ass [ __ ] but it just
i i got social anxiety on like you know
what
it's a long time bro you weren't doing
interviews like that
it was like i remember i ran into you at
a
a session with hit maker yeah yeah i
remember that
first i remember today yeah and uh i
remember i told you like
yo man like i'd love to have you like i
know you don't do interviews like that
but whenever you're ready like you know
i think it'd be dope for people to kind
of just
get to know you a little bit better
because i think people see that whatever
you know we live in a time where people
will just see whatever's on the blogs
and make up their mind about that person
whether it's academics or whatever
blog posts whatever and i think that you
know it's important to
to control your own narrative yeah for
sure you know what i'm saying um
yeah freshman cover big deal
11 plaques finally we have your official
debut album
and um you're on the fast
nine soundtrack that's mine that's
another
dream country right there that's it damn
that's crazy i was saying this
i'm like i gotta get my song in the
movie i gotta manifest this [ __ ]
happen i said three oh i think it was
three
i got one rico nasty on the on the on
the sound you know what no i submitted
three
i think they pick one though but [ __ ] i
submitted three i did three for them
at the end of the day but they picked
that one shout out to rico nasty i saw
she's trolling that she's gonna start at
only fans
gee that's what i saw i mean cardi b
just started an only fans account so at
this point like it's kind of just like
open season like
i saw like even dudes like ddg you know
ddg the youtuber
oh he's also a rapper i don't want to
just put him in that youtube
he records here so that's the homie
shout out ddg um
but he started only fans but on there
he's like giving advice and game
to like up and coming artists and [ __ ]
would you ever do an only fans account
obviously you're not going to be on
their show on your join off but like you
know maybe like exclusive content
for your fans uh you know i feel like
it's
it it could be like an untapped market
low key ain't gonna lie i get on there
but you know what i make my own site to
where my fans they
come they could come subscribe to me
like my own right cause you could like
put your video up for like a week
on only fans first like a music let's
say you got a music video
like yo subscribe to my [ __ ] and you'll
see the video a week but think about it
if you go away from only fans and then
make like
nlp chopper fans oh yes or whatever the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] like they had no subscribers
because i don't want the only fans on
that night like oh no
oh no you want to be you don't want to
be in that group with instagram thoughts
i want my own
yeah yeah yeah i just want my own well
yeah we already when we think of only
fans we think of uh
girls that can no longer sell their
vagina because of kovid so now they're
selling it on the internet god bless
them
god bless social distancing at its best
over the computer over the world wide
web
um yeah that's crazy
uh you also recently became a father for
sure
congratulations you're uh you're still a
kid
i had a my i was pregnant with my son
i wasn't pregnant my baby mama was
pregnant you were pregnant with jose
i have impregnated my baby mama with my
son
my senior year in high school so when i
was 17 my girl was pregnant
uh i think i was just turned 18 when i
had him
um but it was definitely tough being
like a young father i've been in that
position like
what have you uh like taken away from
being a dad so far
ain't gonna lie it's like just change
your whole mindset you gotta stay
positive twenty four seven like i don't
be trying to let negative
just interrupt my mood and not cuz you
gotta at the end of the day think like
you think of
you your daughter and your family so it
really opened my head up to see a lot of
my [ __ ] i started meditating too
it should be helping me with a lot of
[ __ ] so
but the daughter [ __ ] it just opened my
eyes to a lot of more doors
and i just started just going through
them kind of changes the way you think
of [ __ ] yeah for sure i'll be
positive here you know i just be living
day by day i don't try to think too much
of the future so i don't try to think
too much of the pad
when you say you start meditating that's
something that's uh
that's deep man you know what i'm saying
you lived a lot of life for being
your age bro like what got you into
meditating and like
kind of give us a little bit of game on
what that is because i don't think a lot
of people
i think people hear that and they see it
on tv and they think it's like
some like weirdo like hippie [ __ ] yeah
but talk about what the what the
meditation [ __ ] is
man it's really like it's really
peaceful it's like
um you like sometimes you want to feel
alone you want to be by yourself or
something right
right so you would go in the room away
from people you would
normally be with or something right and
you would think that this solving the
solution because you isolate yourself
but really like the piece to find that
peace is like
when i meditate i find that peace i'd be
looking for like i'd be distant
from the world from this world the
little fake [ __ ] we living in i'd be
distant from that [ __ ]
and i just be with myself with my
thoughts and i be controlling my
thoughts
you know just saying what i want and i
just speak like i already have it
i'd be talking like um i'd be praying at
the same time i meditate uh
um i'd be doing a lot of [ __ ] i'd be um
it's just constantly telling myself [ __ ]
so when i get out of there meditation
that's my mindset and this is what i'd
be working to
you know it just changed your way of
thinking it it reprogram your brain like
to out of [ __ ] like hey you better gonna
[ __ ] this
what got you into like starting to do
that like was it a certain person or did
it something you watched like what got
you when you're starting to do that
i come across a video you know
and i was just wondering like no i
always been like i've been getting like
spiritually woke like i be seeing angel
numbers and [ __ ] i don't know if you
know what they mean but
like you'll probably see angel numbers
yeah you you will see it after i talk to
you i bit money you're gonna see it
but it's like i started seeing angel
numbers and a whole lot of [ __ ] and like
oh no it's like spiritually it's like
when once you do [ __ ] spiritually it's
like you
unlock different levels it's hard to
explain it just come
it just kind of me like it come to you
in like different
chapters type [ __ ] it's like here he'll
go a new tool to get through this
chapter
you know and then i just stumble across
a video damn something in my mouth
i stumbled across a video and started my
meditation i tried it and bro i ain't
gonna lie
since i tried it man i've been like
straight i'm gonna be giving nobody
the time of day you yeah time
[Music]
yeah i know the last time we talked i
was telling you like yo man like
you're you have like you can have 10
years
20 years in this game you got the talent
like you're dope don't let
none of the other outside negative like
because you know when i
like obviously i was up on like shadow
flowing like some of the earlier [ __ ]
you would put out but i had known you
more
initially for just the [ __ ] i would see
on on instagram like you arguing with
other rappers or whatever and i'd be
like man this
this kid is dope and it's dope to see
you like
level up mentally you know what i'm
saying because it's gonna extend your
career bro and it's gonna like
make your quality of life like so much
better and that's really what it
at the end of the day the money and all
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] don't matter if your
quality of life is solid
that's real really true happiness you
know what i'm saying and like that's how
you can extend
you know you could be one of these
rappers i mean a lot of your peers that
were around a year and a half ago when
you was
first popping they ain't here no more
and if they are
no one cares like they used to so you
know what i'm saying so
i think you've done a good job of um of
growing man for sure i appreciate that
yeah cause it could be you know we see
it all the time bro with a lot of these
artists where they're just
the antics push the narrative of who
they are
and it's not as much about the music and
it's been dope to see you just
keep leveling up artistically and just
as a man man and like i think a lot of
people too got to realize that you're
going up in front of our eyes bro
yeah i think this is what this should be
crazy everybody saying they're like
i don't hear nobody talking [ __ ] about
this kid he's a kid bro like you know
like we all we all went through some
[ __ ] as a kid we all did dumb [ __ ] when
we were kids like you're growing up in
front of our eyes bro like
you know what i'm saying so i don't i
think i don't been through i ain't gonna
lie it's like i'm growing this man
i ain't even gonna lack like [ __ ] i've
been through i know like
not not a normal
what age did you start to get mixed up
in some of the more street [ __ ] because
obviously
you know a lot of your subject content
is very very aggressive
and is you know was in that world so at
what age did was that
the a side of the world that you were
exposed to and and started to
participate in on any level
like i was always bad as hell like i
remember when i was little like
my next door neighbor this was when i
was probably
i was like six to seven and um he wasn't
even a blood for real
right but he had a red flag he i guess
his big brother gave it to him or
something he had a red flag
i was about six to seven he like three
years older than me
and uh he just walk outside we used to
walk outside with a player there
right then one day he just had me [ __ ]
up like he just walked outside and then
i don't know he was like he had the flag
he was like i'm a blood and he said you
gonna be a blood with me too and i was
like
and like oh no that day i was like it
wasn't the fact that
i didn't want to be a blood it was more
so the fact i wanted to be my own man
like i didn't want to go under his wing
like you know type [ __ ] and i said well
i said if you were blood i said i'm a
[ __ ]
yeah you know what i told him and then
since that day we had started beefing
like i used to always fight with my
neighbor and [ __ ]
and uh like a whole lot of fights in the
neighborhood we ended up moving we had
to move
and [ __ ] i was just bad as hell mom was
like man i ain't gonna lie
i already know what you gonna do out
here so we move but i ain't gonna lie
when i move
i really got even more into gang [ __ ]
cause i was more distance from like
the [ __ ] i was growing up wit so [ __ ]
it was like i was wanting to do this
[ __ ] more because i went
you had to find new friends yeah yeah
and i ain't want to do this so
really really when i really started
doing it was probably
14 like 13. and the thing is too is like
i've met both your parents and they're
great people and like i feel like you
have a great support system yeah it was
perfect it's just me
you have a great support like you have a
great support system i think it's dope
that you keep your parents close to you
because a lot of people
don't do that and they you know they
they become someone who they're not with
this rap [ __ ] and this hollywood [ __ ]
so like from from you getting into
trouble like that when you were like 14
and [ __ ] like
to you rapping like when did you start
taking this rap [ __ ] seriously like dude
i was like 15
because what was it what was the moment
though where you were like oh [ __ ] this
okay like i dropped this song i recorded
this song i was
i think it was when i was 14. i recorded
this song called no love
anthem before i blew up he had 100k on
the audio
like mario mac it was my first son nah
like on youtube okay that's what was
crazy i got 100k on the audio video
right youtube
and then i was like man this [ __ ] crazy
and it was my first song i ever made
my first song i ever dropped and so
when i did it it did age i was like man
i ain't gonna do number get better i
started dropping some more dropping some
more
turn 15 i dropped no chords part three
whole time
i'm i'm i'm i'm flunking in school
i'm getting back up i'm [ __ ] up i'm
telling him but
but i'm telling mama i'm telling my mom
i'm bro it was crazy man
every night i was doing she in her eyes
it was like i was doing
wrong but i was really making my making
my
own lane i was making something i knew
what i was going i knew i was on the
right path because like i said i was
saying angel numbers like four four four
that's teddy on me and i was like mom on
the right path i'm on the right i'm
i got you and i was like and there was
one thing i said i saw i see a lot how a
lot of
[ __ ] treat they must retreat they
pause and [ __ ] like i
i treat i got an attitude i treat them a
certain way but at the same time
a real top shouter know that like you
got to make sure they straight at the
end of the day and the purpose is when
you blow you gotta make sure they good
you
they gotta be with you because if your
family ain't with you you getting fed to
some wolves you wanna you know who
you don't know everyone has [ __ ] up
uh interior motors they got [ __ ] up
deals arterial motors
that's what i was saying when we i'm
like yo when you when you when you when
you
went that united masters route off the
rip i'm like this kid is different
because
we know i mean everybody jumps on that
first advance they get offered
yeah for sure and then they [ __ ] it off
and then they got to pay it back and
it's crazy that was offering me three
meal and [ __ ] i went
through united masters and took 150 000
just to play say
you probably got that three meal within
a few months
and you own the record shout out to
steve stout man
um yeah that's crazy man um
i was it's interesting because i feel
like at the moment
you know every every place has
uh an era in rap right you know there
was west coast
when snoop had it and dre had it and
then obviously it started in new york
and atlanta's had it for a long time but
i do feel like at the moment
for whatever reason man baton rouge is
um baton rouge and where you're from in
memphis
it's like memphis and baton rouge i feel
like it's
it's it's y'all's time you know what i'm
saying you gotta throw in atlanta no but
atlanta is
always gonna be there but i mean memphis
like you guys are
are between memphis and baton rouge you
guys are like
really controlling so much of like the
dance the culture
and the slang and the like
just everything i mean if you look at
like memphis right now it's crazy like
you know what i'm saying there's a lot
of ogs out the city and then
you know yourself and you know i just
talked to dolph yesterday dolph just put
his new album out but like
what is it about memphis right now you
think that is um
it's always been a special place shout
out you know the three six mafia
and everybody who's come out of memphis
but like right now y'all really got it
like
and i feel like there's obviously
dolph's got his issues with gotti but
outside of that
i feel like there's there's some
unification you know i feel like a lot
of the memphis do sweat with each other
i mean it's like
it'd be it'd be hard to explain like
it'd be kind of hard to explain it's
real hard to explain it's like
at the same time it's like it'd be
different side so you got north memphis
south memphis east memphis
but like it's like everybody be on their
own [ __ ] like everybody
a lot of people be on their own [ __ ]
everybody click out with their own gang
and then like
i don't know everybody be on their own
stuff i feel like that's why it'd be
like a lot of people coming out of it
but like everybody be on my own stuff
and then and y'all make that music you
feel me
then it's like they click i don't know
how this [ __ ] be fool it'd be weird as
hell
it's like we'd be apart and then
together it did
well because i feel like you're like
you're like your own little island in
memphis
like i feel like you're not like a
philly i feel like at some point in time
people are either affiliated with cmg or
or pr like paper route or something and
then there's
there's this 17 year old kid who's
low-key like you know probably the most
lit kid out the city right now and like
you're kind of like your own entity
that's what i like to meet
i can i like to be on my own what's that
country in the middle of europe that's
like independent
is it scandinavia or switzerland
switzerland they
they're they're neutral on everything
they just their own little you know
you know they they got they got no
affiliation you're like switzerland in
memphis bro
uh you got any relationships with um i
know the grizzlies are uh
you know they about to hopefully make
the playoffs with this playing game but
you know john moran is obviously going
to be a superstar you got any uh
have you you guys tapped in at all
together if so he's just following me on
twitter we just follow each other on
twitter
i um i tweeted them i said memphis
shooters like the grizzlies in one of my
songs
i tagged them so yeah and then we
supposed to hoop i supposed to
pull it up at the gym hoop with them but
[ __ ] i was in cold
and also the covet [ __ ] you know can you
imagine what kind of [ __ ] he'd get in if
there was a video like
john marantz not taking covet 19 series
as he plays basketball with nle choppa
on the album dude you have you know the
record that really hit me was the
depression record which i thought
uh melodically is an incredible song but
just the content of the record i feel
like
you know not a lot of people deal with
um their depression openly
and it's a it's kind of like a subject
that doesn't get a lot of uh
that probably doesn't get as much
coverage as it is because i think a lot
of people sometimes are ashamed that
they feel like they're depressed or
they're in a dark place and then we find
out someone dies because they overdose
or they kill themselves or some [ __ ]
i mean look like to hear a song from a
16 16
17 year old kid about depression is
crazy because my my son's 14 in
in the next room like um talk about your
battle with depression like you know
what i'm saying like and and how serious
that was and like
you know why you why you choose to be
open with it with the world
it's like i don't know i feel like ain't
nothing you used to be ashamed to have
it because it actually helps in a
certain way because like people know
that
you know they perceive me as a hype
[ __ ] i don't be hype like that i'd be
cool
but in your videos you'd be hype as [ __ ]
yeah i'd be happy with my videos
it's like a switch it's like a switch
yeah i just be cooling but
i don't know that was something i always
do with depression like because i was
always
different i just was always different
like i said i always wanted
you went this way i wanted to go that
way like i didn't want to just you know
and [ __ ] this is just it made it hard
for a lot of people to get along with me
for me to keep
[ __ ] going with people because i was
just always different as [ __ ] nobody
knew how to adapt to me so
[ __ ] started [ __ ] would hate on me so
i had to you know it was just a lot of
[ __ ]
and a lot of problems since i was
younger today here but
when i got when i said i dropped my
album i lost myself doing my
album type [ __ ] i lost myself making my
own but then when i dropped it
i said i found myself again because
that's around the time i started
meditating
and like when you put it in your mind
that you don't have it like that you
don't have a personal you don't have
anxiety
like you keep saying it in your head
like it gets worse probably
no it gets better it does get better
okay you it's like when you
you know you cool you don't have it you
just be like
was that white cause it's like because
your brain gonna tear you wait yo it's
your brain to see your whole reality
it's gonna if you that's how i was i was
like mom the prison citizen you know
that's how i'm feeling but if i just
changed my thought looked at all the
positive and kept thinking about the
puzzle
yo much were you in like because i do
feel like you had a few episodes where
you were on ig live that were kind of
wild like was that like
you yeah you had some crazy ig live
episodes i was like yo what the hell
i just be tweaking someone get this man
was that was that because of the
depression or was it because of drugs or
like what were you going through at
those times because you had some wild
[ __ ] going on man
i don't know because like and then i
that's
you know when i talked to you i was like
yo man like you got this bro
like you know what i'm saying like and
then okay like you're obviously a smart
kid you have your head on straight
but there was some times where like you
you were at some low points and the
whole world saw
yeah i was mad at him i just be mad a
little mad ass
little sad ass [ __ ] man but cool now
[ __ ] i'm gonna do that [ __ ] be cool of
mine trying to see better days
i got a daughter there's so much more i
can look forward to yes sir
um the legacy of you doing shadow flow
right because it's obviously
we're on five now right now i'm through
i'm through yeah and it was dead
but now there's top shot of flow right
mm-hmm no wait
what was that there's another one that
that's on the album
though yeah um what i
what i think is dope is unlike most
people who are in your uh
lane or your peers rather in hip-hop
right now like you you make it an
emphasis
and a point to make sure you're like a
dope rapper yeah cuz i don't [ __ ] i
don't feel like i don't get talked about
enough
no but you're you're like you're you
know like
there's some of this new [ __ ] i just
can't listen to because it's it's i
i don't know if it's because i'm an old
head or but i appreciate people who
actually rap and you're actually like a
dope rapper
so like what what uh when you were
growing up
growing you still growing up but like
what was what was some of the
more lyrical rap [ __ ] that like kind of
influenced you to um
you know kind of put more of an emphasis
on the on on the on the bars and making
sure you ain't like you know
my pops like he's just stay bumping um
tupac
and ugk and umc button b all that yeah
oh it is so it was really the music i
grew up offering chief keith
all this stuff so you get a mix about it
i just feel like
the gangsters get especially ugk audio
come on man if there was one og
that you haven't worked with yet who's
like the og that would be like your like
bucket list feature like if you could
work with somebody obviously somebody
who's still alive like who would that be
i really was why ain't really wayne
wayne just they go back to the shatter
flow thing
yeah i see it that's the only way i make
another shadow flow with it is it for
one
six six yeah i'm great have you had any
communication with wayne or i mean i'm
sure he knows who you are
not they said he'll be on oh no i think
he'd be distant from a lot of [ __ ] that
is true
and he's like in love now yeah so i'd
just be cool
[ __ ] so wayne is the guy who'll get you
to do another shot of flow
hey wayne the tick on the shutter flow
you ain't i want to hear
you've mentioned ugk which is one of my
favorite raglers i feel like you and bun
b would do uh
have you ever heard the ugk record
murderer i don't think so
listen man if you remade that record
i'ma play it for you before you leave
i probably have possibly probably played
it i know diamonds and wolves
if you did like a 20 20 version of that
it's in your bag bro and put bun
on it and you feel like yeah of course
um yeah that'd be crazy though wayne
yeah we got to make that let's put that
into the world man we gotta do that put
that shot of flow six
that's the only way shout out for six
weezy
yeah man bun b um a lot of i've noticed
a lot of artists are
uh a lot more artists at least are doing
like collab projects together
right like you know eps together some
people are doing albums together
is there an artist who you would um
who you think you would like you could
see yourself doing
an entire project with one of the homies
somebody who you're close with um
i have to do like a table with
blackboard like me and black
yo i saw him did he give you the dance
moves because i saw him in the video and
y'all was you know
yeah we were going up we was turning up
in top shutter flow
yeah yeah we yo shout out to blockboy
also i feel like blackboard don't get
talked about enough
blackboard jb he just dropped in no
dribble freestyle
yo block was fired too yeah
that [ __ ] had on my jacket bro let me
get my [ __ ] jacket back
he had on your jacket in the video hey
i'm on his ass
damn but jack i gave him someone though
you talked about chief keith how
important was it for you to do
uh a shot of play with chief keef and
she was amazing
cause like one of my sons i said
no i ain't gonna speak on this song
y'all gonna have to wait for this song
it's not out yet mm-hmm i ain't gonna
say no about that song
but like this one of the [ __ ] i looked
up to we were doing drills off his music
pretty much right chief that was the guy
was was was
sometimes when we meet people like that
i know so many people i looked up to as
a kid
i met him and been disappointed was like
he cool as [ __ ] like
like like was was the like the
interaction with him dope like
he cool you cool i don't be too much in
a [ __ ] face i just
know we just cooling i'd be on my own
it's just
i don't know how much music you're
sitting on right now
400 500. you had a song where you remade
uh
the uh young bleed masterpiece [ __ ]
the how you do that there that you did
with hitmaker ah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i heard that in the studio and i was
like bro
this [ __ ] this is go go
oh i forgot about this you just need to
throw it to bootleg cab because i'm
putting a project out we'll make it a
bootleg kept single you know what i'm
saying we'll
put some features on it you know what
i'm saying yeah i mean otherwise you're
just gonna sit on the hard drive
i gotta list someone with a guy i don't
think i like it no more i gotta listen
to that that [ __ ] was hard
hey for you see how the brain work
that's how you know i'm listening to you
you see how you picked up your award and
i picked up mine ah
is is crazy meditation bruh
[ __ ] a little dry as a [ __ ] you
changing look at this video there's like
you been licking his lip the whole damn
video
we got are we gonna backward appearance
ladies and gentlemen um
are you changing diapers bro you letting
the girl do that and the parents do that
yeah it sounds like have you had one of
the it was weird at first though because
he's a girl it was weird but i changed
have you had your daughter [ __ ] on you
on accident yet no no
no no no no no no oh yeah wait till
that's going to happen buddy
you you go to change that diaper you
think they're done and then
my [ __ ] said the little boys they're
pissing on you you'll get hit with that
straight shot man you're gonna hit
get hit with the straight not even
realizing all of a sudden it's like god
damn i just got [ __ ] on
that's a real thing man yo baby [ __ ] on
you
now don't let your baby get diarrhea did
you go to change the diarrhea diaper
and you think it's they're done and then
they just you know just keep running
it's just it is it can happen
you turn 18 in november november 1st
are you going to be able to vote in
november yeah but i ain't gonna lie bro
bro i might sound crazy for him
but gee i think
kanye was down there the best candidate
out of these two [ __ ]
you think kanye is the best candidate
out of joe and trump
what i mean for when he don't count
joe and trump
it's just some bad thing i'm not gonna
lie to you it is probably the
worst selection of candidates we've ever
had
the worst in the world it's it's um like
you know they usually say
like the less of two evils right but it
i don't think it's ever been more true
than it is right now yeah it's it's
scary right now
but it's really scary but i for sure
would have went with kanye
over both of them oh great listen
i love kanye but uh
i'ma just i'ma just uh i'ma hold my nose
look the other way
you gotta think though i'm just trying
to get trump up out of there you feel me
he ain't gonna be making all the
decisions by himself
kanye the president don't make all this
decision i feel you but i don't know
he gonna have a lot of people around him
but you know the lady who
who's gonna be his vice president is
like an insane
lady from wyoming who's like a
spiritual healer i don't know man it's i
don't know it's
it's some real shout out to kanye's my
favorite artist ever
do i any kanye art anywhere anyway uh i
wanna have spiritual years i wanna talk
cause i think you could be spiritual but
not be religious are you
more spiritual or you really you
consider yourself religious like i'm not
religious
i just believe in a god i know i know a
god i know
a god created all this you know no way i
know he created this world but a lot of
people get
a lot of people get lost in like the
world is a living thing itself too he
created
the world a living thing too so what you
put out in the world
is she gonna put back you know what you
put out so i for sure believe it's a god
ain't no way
this is just a prayer but the way you
know that they say
i don't know about it well you know the
pentagon just uh put out a press release
i don't know if you saw this but they
they've uh officially the government has
acknowledged that ufos
exist did you see that i ain't gonna
laugh
i believe that aliens haircut i like
this [ __ ] i already heard
oh no i think so too but i'm just
curious like if the uh the thought of
aliens being real kind of [ __ ] up
the premise of a lot of religions being
real i think somebody
some of you [ __ ] i'm saying some of
them [ __ ] they put on the tv
smile like who man i need an example
i'm trying to look out for these aliens
you feel me bro
you mean to me elon musk's not an alien
yo
that's the bro it's funny you said elon
musk
he's the only person that in my head
i've thought to myself
if anyone's a [ __ ] alien it's that
weird [ __ ] elon
come on bro he trying to get people to
go to mars
well you know he's trying to install uh
he's got a uh
a company called euro uh neurologic
right and what they're doing in san
francisco is they're developing
technology
where they cut a piece of your skull out
of your head and they install a chip
and the chip meshes with your brain so
that's
like and this one you [ __ ] with god
creation at this point
that's what when i heard that i'm like
yo elon musk on some other [ __ ] bro
you got some cute cars and [ __ ] but that
[ __ ] is crazy you don't need that
they like the raw g no i said yeah i
need to meditate yeah i need to
better take cause this [ __ ] going that
way i'm gonna be [ __ ] with this [ __ ]
yeah i think uh i think would like if if
that becomes the normal in the future
would you get a chip put in your brain
hey oh no you know
yeah you're gonna be living in a
technology
no yeah i wouldn't bruh that i ain't
no yeah i think i think elon musk could
be an alien i mean if i had to bet on
anyone being an alien
he he's definitely the favorite for sure
he's like the lakers in the playoffs
they got to be the favorite right now
you know what i'm saying elon's got to
be the alien either him or maybe sean
hannity or somebody like that
because you can't say you can't bruh you
can't
look fool if a [ __ ] come to my face
and say hey man let's move to mars let's
move to mars let's move to mars
he said i've been there his head lived
there before it ain't no [ __ ]
way
your way i just want to say let go to
mars and we feel the live on
[ __ ] first off they say as hot as hell
there so we ain't gonna be thinking
about going there
[ __ ] let's go to mars the [ __ ]
no been
will you even drive a tesla because i
[ __ ] with that tesla truck that they put
out i'm trying to get that thing but i
don't know man
it could be a trap you feel me kind of
police the tesla's kind of the police it
kind of is
[ __ ] police the [ __ ] computer's in
the middle of your car lord knows what's
getting recorded these phones out and
[ __ ] alexa
oh this [ __ ] you gotta you got the alexa
at the crib
like yeah but sometimes when i be saying
certain [ __ ] my siri come on
yeah yeah that's crazy
i mean there i guess there's a lot of
stuff we could dive into with that but
[ __ ] all that yo man quick break in the
podcast to tell you about our sponsor
odd socks all right make sure you go to
odd socksofficial.com oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg calf and you'll
save 20
when you check out they got crazy
licenses on socks they got man listen
let's pull out these ric flair joints
all right they got ric flair wwe
nickelodeon
how about some chucky for halloween
coming up
or just some basic joints they got the
odd socks basics line
one more time everything you need really
you need the most comfortable socks in
the world on your feet go to
oddssocksofficial.com and use the
keyword bootleg cab at checkout
and you'll save 20 off that's
oddssoxoficial.com
back to the podcast um your album is out
it's a great body of work i'm sure that
uh
are you gonna make everyone wait for the
second album
as long as they had to wait for the
first album well i'm trying to pull up
the looks out soon
yeah the new the deluxe play is the new
wave right it's like
it's kind of like a little loophole to
get them like to double up on the album
sales
yeah it's kind of like a whole new album
like the baby just put out 10 new songs
is your deluxe going to be 10 um
they said they want to do facts i did i
just did 20
on my album so i don't know they want to
do five with me
i want to go b i'm going to want to get
400 songs buddy that's what i'm saying i
can't as well just throw ten more [ __ ]
do you know who's gonna be on the deluxe
dude do we have any idea like or is it
just gonna be you or
um right now i don't think i got some no
features on there right now but oh
i ain't really just too much get into
just working on it on it cause i think i
got no signs of where i can put on there
but
i don't know i just been in the process
of thinking like what approach i'm going
to take when i record my new [ __ ]
or do i put some of this some of this
[ __ ] some more [ __ ] they've been waiting
on on here so
it's just been me thinking i just got to
mix them up in a way
uh walk them down is a great record and
i feel like you and roddy are kind of
like two leaders of
the new generation um it was dope to see
all work together
with child's relationship like and is
there any more any more music
together that maybe y'all have recorded
that we haven't heard yet
now we we ain't got nothing else yet but
[ __ ] he pretty much he had a big year
uh you know he got to eat that europe
for sure
then you come back i can see do we want
to make another one but
we for sure gonna get one in and get
another one there here you see that [ __ ]
we can get one in here
have you um because i i know i was
talking to his team about just
some of the festival money that they
missed out on because of cover 19.
the live show [ __ ] is [ __ ] up have you
uh have you had to like kind of adjust
your hustle and figure out other ways to
monetize what you're doing because of
the fact that the shows are not
happening
um i'm really just too much like me i'm
weird man i don't really just too much
focus on money and [ __ ] for
like i ain't gonna cap like
i got a bank i got a savings out of it i
let my dudes handle
it i just yeah you know i don't need too
much
toe cash on me and i don't really just
live about money this [ __ ] don't excite
me
let your mom kind of invest yeah she do
all this [ __ ] i don't know
probably the best thing to do man i
don't know a lot of 17 year old kids
that would handle millions of dollars
the right way
my kid would spend it all on vc on nba
2k
that's all i do be running my card up on
my league game though i
i buy a whole lot of um packages on my
not mad crap what the [ __ ] wrong with me
girl i meant to say call of duty call of
duty
how about i say [ __ ] about to say my
eight-year-old likes minecraft
and uh gta2 i used to i remember when i
was young full on guy when i was young i
used to play gta and i used to be broke
on gta and broke in real life
i used to be like broke on gta man cause
like
they just wanna do missions and [ __ ] i
ain't feel like doing all that [ __ ] i
just
like robbing the stores and [ __ ] i had
pocket chains on my character until a
glitch come out i
hit them glitches but then i see them
when i get rich fool i'm just bowed
um about a little money yeah i should be
buying eight million on their air time i
get on that video
have you spent a lot of time on the on
the call of duty [ __ ] since they put out
the uh
what's the [ __ ] called warzone [ __ ]
what's on here yeah i'll be on twitch
i was just twitching with the face
playing dude right here yeah i got a
twitch
that's what i've been um i've been on
twitch i've been trying to do something
this should be
you get something on twitch bro for so i
need
i gotta put that in there i'm gonna put
that in i'll make something up there too
so you be on twitch that's like that is
that something that you just started to
do was it twitch [ __ ] it's something i
always wanted to do
actually it's hard to understand it
right like yo how do these [ __ ]
are like playing
set it up for me oh god i ain't touched
nothing i just they set it up
and then they sent me down there they
was like i don't think i know how to do
click to go live but
never me i just play that [ __ ]
and then this [ __ ] he'd be hacking my
computer
he'd be doing all the [ __ ] for me like
while i'm sitting there and he don't
need to be there he'll be in a whole
nother house cause i was like what the
[ __ ] i was like that's a police saying
i'm like
i'm like what if he'd be hearing this
because he gonna watch his interview
he [ __ ] like if you see him what
you'll be looking at on the internet
[ __ ]
he can go through all they could he can
type to he can go to
anything from a whole another place cuz
y'all what the [ __ ] yeah now i got a
homie that does that too
he'd be giving me all the hack programs
and he's in arizona and i just give him
access
remotely to my computer and just let
them
install everything that i need you know
what i'm saying yo when you read that
record with mulatto uh
record is dope but uh i feel like it's
awkward for me to listen to a child
speak about the things you spoke about
on that song
obviously you're a father uh but like
wha
what was uh what was the vibe like with
her making that record because it's a
very explicit
record like i said i'm a grown man
a.d female 8 [ __ ] nobody man oh girl
yeah i would probably i i mean let me
stop me if i'm wrong but i'm assuming
you've probably slept with more women
that are
um overaged then what i'm saying yeah
what's the oldest oh
she was like 40
40 something for this song she ain't
look 40 though
yeah she knew that i want to say 47 for
47. but she will find
it's
damn you you definitely [ __ ] someone's
mom then
for soap yeah so and
did she know you were under age so she's
like did you know
we're dealing with a uh we're dealing
with a pedo here no
she she achomo technique
you're a grown ass man i understand that
but technically she's a child molester
but not really though because
technically most of the women you [ __ ]
they're child molesters
technically not really though cause
guess what if she was if she was 18
right it would be to sign in charge it
depends on what state you're in i think
there's a three-year window in certain
states
but 47 that's that's some child
molesting that [ __ ]
look at this the last interview we did
your mom was in the room and she was
like
do you remember that yeah shout out to
your mom
and shout out to the 47 year old woman
who
what is is this uh like
she fine bro did you meet her on
instagram or did you meet her at it's
like where did you meet a 47 year old in
the airport
wow
47 in an airport you didn't sleep with
her at the airport did you
no no no no no does that have been that
i mean i want to do that though
i do that for you at the airport or in
the plane at the airport
in on the planet see the only thing that
sucks about the plane is
the only place unless you you probably
fly private because you're in elite
chopper
i fly flat i fly yeah but you get into
that bathroom and you think this is the
only place i can [ __ ] is this little ass
bathroom
and i just i've i've been in there
taking a [ __ ] on a flight and been like
could i actually have sex
oh god i'd be thinking i ain't gonna
laugh sometimes on the flight they cut
the lights off no food
oh yeah you could definitely catch a
hand job on the planet
under the blanket all day you know and
no one will notice if it's if it's dark
it's a you know if it's a nice red eye
give a [ __ ] pink eye on the red eye you
feel me
i just feel like a real piece of [ __ ]
that i'm having a conversation like this
with a goddamn
kid that's not even 18. but you are
you're a father so i'm just going to
give you
we're both fathers so we're bonding on i
got a daughter baby clover it's terrible
breaking my name
you've gotten a lot of new tattoos yeah
recently
by myself um
was there it has a couple questions
what's the most painful tattoo and which
one have you regretted if any
have you regretted it because you know
[ __ ] are getting tattoos off
the rip that they regret later on
hang on like tattoos they ain't painful
to me they'd be like a therapy maybe put
me to sleep like my stomach tattoo
i feel asleep on that big [ __ ] they
said they said you youngster food they
say
ain't nobody ever fell asleep on the
stomach tech but you spit
oh ko'd in the chair what about do you
have
a tattoo you've regretted getting you
know i got a chance
like you know which one like is it it's
a tattoo like
i regretted getting but i had covered up
i had covered it up
i had covered it up so it's covered up
now what was it prior
it was like a name of an ex
like just a person just like a like a
47 year old or an x an actor
yeah yeah i mean it wasn't it wasn't
dead it wasn't the spec of that
that wasn't why i covered it i was just
like like i just wanted a rose i was
like my name rose would be hard
well also like i hope you learned your
lesson like never get a woman's tattooed
on
on you that's that's not your mom or
your daughter my mama teddy right here
though no i'm saying like you know
that's
that's great because you'll never have
to cover that up i never had to
but you know any other type of female
i says the guy i got my wife's name
tattooed on my finger but we're married
but uh but yeah you know don't get any
females in the tattooed unless they got
a ring on their finger
fam yeah say less my guy i appreciate
you uh the new album is out
you're on that freshman cover which is a
big look
them ciphers are going to be dropping
soon can't wait to see what you come up
with in them things
i hope my psycho came out great did you
uh bond with anybody at the chute
or was it just kind of like you know you
kind of you know like you say you're
kind of
talking to right right cool cool
open-minded dude
mulatto was there it was in groups
always in groups roy little tj
dan yeah chica and then
um he keeps saying she's in the
background because i think you guys are
all the same level label bro i ain't
gonna like
my memory [ __ ] off name well it's good
but
it's good but it's just like it'd be
hard to remember certain things
well look man album is out go support it
and uh
top shout out man go get that get out of
him on that twitch and nelly choppa
music one
twitter and nelly chopper one anybody
and
and hide your mother from this guy
because he he's he's a real [ __ ]
i changed bro that was that was
that was hey speaking hey that's how i
was really speaking about
i ain't like that no more bro i don't
i'm he's meditating now i'm protecting
my energy i don't know he's not a
[ __ ] anymore i don't give all my
energy like that i'm not i'm not please
don't paint that picture on me i'm a
good guy no i got a daughter
i got a daughter yeah yeah no leaf
news in the past when you were 15.
yo last question do you have your
driver's license bro no okay i didn't
think so
we're just going to leave it right there
i just don't feel like going in there
and like doing the person waiting in
line
cause i still gotta do the permit too
busy
so i gotta get somebody to make me one
hey
hey and then the chopper one oh twitter
hey i got some guys on the dark web
that'll take care of you buddy i could
get you a nice idea